our favorite disney princesses come from
under the sea just around the riverbend
and frozen scandinavian kingdoms
but what if they came from the land of
fairies
today we're transforming disney royalty
into their winx club fairy alter egos
is it possible to make elsa even icier
we think
yes we'll be pulling ariel out of the
sea so she can get her wings and fly
let tiana's hair come down and she'll be
one step closer to crystallizing morphix
get ready to dive into the winx club
fairy world with the best of disney
[Music]
royalty
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a transformation how great is it to
see princesses
and princes transformed while all the
characters had their own magic to begin
with we can't help but
love these fairy alter egos maybe there
should be a disney fairy spin-off
which winx club character is your
favorite do you prefer princess tiana or
fairy tiana let us know what you think
in the comments section
if you enjoyed be sure to subscribe to
our channel and hit that like button